I've been saying for the record that the
show is gonna end since season two
I mean you've hinted at the end of
Gray's I know you've been asked that a
lot but is the end here I have no idea
you know I I always say it and then you
know it's something Shonda and I will
sit down and decide together when the
time is you know I it's obviously I've
been doing it a long time and I do get
restless but the fans are just still so
passionate about the show and when you
meet people you know that that are going
through things in their life and they
say that the show brings them solace the
show brings them comfort whether they
have cancer whether they're an abuse
victim whether they're in a marginalized
community and the show gives them some
sort of brings them some sort of comfort
to know that you're really touching
people even if it is just a silly soap
opera to know that you're really
touching people and making people feel
better even if it's just because they're
crying yeah you know it's meaningful I
think as an actor what we want to do is
tell stories and have those stories
reach people right and template seasons
I mean yeah and we are really really
touching people's lives you know I see
the effects of it every day I hear the
stories people come up to me we're
really we really make a difference in
people's lives
and I think as an artist to be able to
touch people you know in a meaningful
way on something as silly as a TV show
you know I you know I I don't take it
for granted that's for sure I appreciate
it
how will you and Shonda like know when
it's time to actually close this chapter
close this book I think the fans will
let us know really yeah yeah when the
numbers start to drop and no one's you
know people are watching the same people
aren't as passionate about it it's time
to call it okay so until then you're
still down to keep going okay right now
let's take one season at a time that's
true
[Music]